these people's homes and businesses for
economic development projects Stephen
green HUD considers the issue in his new
book abuse of power how the government
misuses eminent domain his talk from
borders books in Yorba Linda California
is 45 minutes welcome everybody my name
is Tibor McCain I'm a business ethics
professor at Chapman University in
Orange California I am extremely happy
and honored to introduce to you Steve
green HUD who's a veteran journalist at
the Orange County Register and he's
authored a fabulous book - which I wrote
a foreword called
abuse of power this book chronicles is
one of the saddest spectacles in our
economy were big business which is
supposed to be a supporter of free
enterprise is in fact violating all the
principles of free enterprise by
bringing in the feds and the local
governments to unseat existing
businesses so that they can muscle in
the rest of it I'll let Steve take care
of thank you very much Steve thanks
Steve or thanks for showing up everyone
I really appreciate it
eminent domain is when the government
takes property by force upon
compensation to the owner after due
process is given I hope your eyes aren't
glazing over yet it gets more
interesting but today and this is the
shocking thing a public use means a
Costco or a car dealership and just
compensation means being offered pennies
on the dollar
imagine if it's your property your
life's work to be driven out for a
Costco and B be offered pennies on the
dollar by a city and having and you have
to hire a costly lawyer to fight back
and get fair compensation and due
process means learning about the taking
by reading about it in the newspaper
so that's hardly what our founding
fathers had in mind
if we've reached the sorry state in
America because Americans no longer
believe and understand and property
rights and the
they have in protecting all of us one of
the most persistent myths is that
property rights mainly benefit the rich
and powerful my book abuse of power how
the government misuses eminent domain
shows how property rights are the
fundamental protection for all of us
including the weak and the powerless I
quote in the book something from a guy
named Stephen Hill he's director of some
group and watchman in Washington a
rights in a Washington newspaper but
he's expressing a common misperception
especially among those on the political
left the Bill of Rights and Constitution
were really there to guarantee the
property rights of the rich and rich
wannabes he wrote the nation's
inequalities are a direct result of the
priority given by the Bill of Rights and
the US Constitution to protect the
private property of rich individuals and
wealthy corporations over basic human
rights oh really that's not an honest
something you would think after reading
abuse of power which documents other way
the little guy is driven out of business
to benefit guys like Donald Trump a
better understanding of what property
rights are all about to all of us comes
from British Prime Minister William Pitt
and he had this to say about property
rights the poorest man may in his
cottage bid defiance to all the forces
of the crown it may be frail its roof
may shake the wind may blow through it
the storm may enter the rain may enter
but the King of England cannot enter all
his forces dare not cross the threshold
of the ruined tenement it's a
wonderfully radical idea an idea that
the founding fathers embraced but today
any two-bit city manager City Council
can have more power than the King of
England they could come into your
property take it from you and give it to
Costco or Home Depot or any number of
businesses that they think are more
worthy for any reason at all that they
think as as important now fast-forward
about 180 years from William Pitt
statement to 1981 and the Detroit
neighborhood known as pole town was a
well-kept ethnically diverse
working-class neighborhood originally
settled by poles the area had more than
a thousand homes six hundred businesses
several churches in a hospital it's one
of the nicer more settled neighborhoods
in
Detroit at the time there wasn't
anything wrong with it except that it
was in an area coveted by General Motors
which was threatening to build its new
Cadillac assembly plant out of state if
city leaders didn't use eminent domain
to clear away the neighborhood so
Detroit officials backed by influential
business Civic and religious leaders
argued that Poletown must be destroyed
for the good of the region and
unfortunately the state Supreme Court
agreed at the time that the project was
proper under the fifth amendment much
earlier in the century the court still
interpreted the Fifth Amendment in a
traditional manner public use meant
courthouses highways schools bridges
dams railroads and other infrastructure
that's obviously what public means but
in 1954 in the Supreme Court case Berman
versus Parker the court agreed that the
District of Columbia could condemn
private property and hand it over to
private developers for private gain
provided the appropriate legislative
body deemed that a public use so as long
as the Congress at the time decided that
that was an appropriate use what was the
court to say that's what they argued
here here they said one one common
phrase if those who govern the District
of Columbia decide that the nation's
capital should be beautiful as well as
sanitary there's nothing in the Fifth
Amendment that stands in the way it's a
decision that sounds more like a
sociology textbook than a reflection of
the reflection of the founders wisdom
now 1950s Washington there was
admittedly real blight which is supposed
to be the pretext for using eminent
domain for redevelopment activities in
1981 though the Michigan Court said
blight needn't even be found the mere
promise of regional economic improvement
was sufficient reason to bulldoze an
entire neighborhood and now it's gotten
worse from there in recent years cities
across the country have used Poletown to
justify the most outlandish schemes some
of the people here in the audience have
been victims of some of these schemes
sometimes they're stopped by courts or
political actions but only sometimes and
only after property owners have had a
fight tooth and nail and sometimes spend
an awful lot of money on lawyers to win
the day a nearby Cypress California
officials
voted to use eminent domain to give
cottonwood christian centers property to
costco the officials were just blatant
in what they argued they said that the
transfer was a public use
because costco paid more taxes than a
church so imagine that as the standard
of property rights anytime the
government could find some somebody who
could pay more taxes than you then they
could drive you off your land and I
imagine Costco could always pay more
taxes than virtually any other use any
any of us could could come up with which
means that an essence property rights
don't exist now a compromise was reached
after a federal court issued a
preliminary injunction but it was a long
difficult fight and I'll introduce later
one of the attorneys who who was
involved in that fight also a nearby
nearby in Garden Grove California the
city notorious abusers of property
rights there they tried to condemn an
entire neighborhood with about a
thousand residents a few of which are
here today so the city could market the
property to a theme park developer they
didn't even have a developer in mind
that we're just going to condemn the
area and try to find a theme park
developer the council ultimately back
down under pressure from the community
but it was a lot of hard work and to
bring a thousand people out to council
meeting and to save their homes in
Lakewood Ohio I mean this is a national
problem it's not just California
although we often here tend to be on the
cutting edge of every good and bad trend
in Lakewood Ohio the city tried to
bulldoze a historic neighborhood
beautiful neighborhood that was on prime
park front property and they wanted to
give it to a developer who promised to
drive out the middle class residents and
build fancy condos and they promised
that well the new residents would be
shopping at fancy stores and going to
nice restaurants and that would provide
more revenue for the city so how's that
for justification they called these
lovely homes blighted because they
lacked air conditioning and attached
garages so as they say any excuse serves
a tyrant and redevelopment officials
will come up with any excuse to blight
properties so that they can take it and
give it to somebody who's promising the
city big tax payoffs the residents
stopped the action with a referendum and
a recall election but many many of these
projects go forward as
especially when officials don't
overreach so much that the projects
gained attention in Newcastle New York
the city drove a poor african-american
church off its land to make way for a
shopping center in Atlantic City in one
of the earliest and most famous cases
the Redevelopment Agency tried pushing
an elderly widow out of her home so that
Donald Trump could build a parking lot
for his casinos limousines now imagine
that as a public use driving a widow off
of her beautiful home so that Donald
Trump could have a parking lot for his
limousine so obviously things have
gotten pretty far from the original
founders concept before Poletown and
Chavez Ravine in Los Angeles a Mexican
American neighborhood was leveled
initially to make way for public housing
but ultimately to create Dodger Stadium
smoke this is a small sampling of a
nationwide problem and those who think
property rights are for the rich have
never thought about these cases where
lower and middle income people are
abused at the hands of important movers
and shakers such as Donald Trump Costco
and condo developers a Wall Street
Journal writer John Fund refers to loot
which stands for leaders of our town it
reinforces how the influential people in
a community usually side with the new
project and some of the folks here could
can attest to that that they didn't get
a lot of support from the from the
movers and shakers in the community so
often to fight back you really have to
mount a grassroots effort and
fortunately on July 31st 23 years after
residents of Poletown were driven from
their property the Michigan Supreme
Court unanimously overturned the
Poletown decision it's a little late for
the original residence but the case will
help others it's a very important case
and and there is some push in a more
rational direction there are more cases
that are that are upholding property
rights but abuses are still rampant the
court in that overturning of Poletown
they described the original Poletown
decision as a radical departure from
fundamental constitutional principles if
one's ownership of private property is
forever subject to the government's
determination that another private party
would be would put one's land to better
use than the ownership of real property
is perpetually threatened by the
banshan plans of any large discount
retailer mega store or the like as the
court understood when eminent domain has
abused the rich and powerful take
advantage of the poor the middle class
and those who lack influence and it took
23 years to recognize that that concept
is very important concept
now abuse of power looks at the many
abuses it tells the stories of the
property owners who are victimized in
the process it looks at the unjust way
that just compensation is provided
people who have to fight often they're a
small business owner I think of in
Garden Grove driven off their property
they no longer have a source of income
they were recent immigrants they didn't
have the money to fight back but somehow
they had they had to find tens of
thousands of dollars to mount a campaign
to get just compensation they eventually
got it but they had to pay the lawyers
fee so it's a really unfair process and
it puts their life on hold for a long
time the book also focuses on the
bizarre totalitarian mentality of some
redevelopment officials in one case that
I mentioned the redevelopment director
said that for progress to take place she
was justifying this outrageous eminent
domain process she said someone's skin
must be left on the sidewalk but I
imagine it wasn't her skin she was
talking about locally I was at a city
council meeting where one mayor
instructed abused property owners that
the city is like the parent and the
property owners are like the children
who only want what they see that's a
direct quote now how would the founders
or how would anyone who loves freedom
respond to such views I mean that's not
the American Way
now abuse of power looks at the urban
renewal schemes that that have created
this process the impact on religious
organizations because churches and other
religious organizations don't pay taxes
cities don't want to let them build on
their land and often will drive them off
their property to give it to tax
producing businesses so it's it's a it's
a terrible thing for for religious
groups there's a chapter on the
corporate welfare queens that abused
this process and also on my profession
the media which used to be pretty
unsympathetic to abuse property owners
say what they would often write stories
that would trump at the great new scheme
was being proposed to do kind of civic
boosterism but that's changing and I've
seen more and more stories starting to
cover the issue more seriously most
important the book explains how to fight
back through community organizing
political activities and legal action
and it mentions one city just across the
freeway in Anaheim California that's
taking a different approach instead of
using eminent domain to redevelop old
areas it's loosening up zoning
restrictions thus increasing the value
of older areas and allowing the market
to work on its own that's a much more
appropriate way of redevelopment and
it's a good alternative to this process
because officials always say well what
are we supposed to do to redevelop areas
the key point is property rights protect
us all as one chapters titled property
rights are human rights and the sooner
we recognize that the sooner we can put
an end to the abuses that take place by
cities and other governments thanks I'd
like to introduce a few people who will
just make some some comments people who
have been involved with some of the
local Orange County issues they've
watched as eminent domain has been
abused locally one here is Assemblyman
Lou Korea who he talked he met with a
lot of the residents in Garden Grove and
maybe you have a comment or two thank
you very much Steve if very briefly
knows I'd listen to Steve talk I'm
reminded of the founding fathers of this
country the way they establish
government three branches those three
branches were set up so they can check
each other off in terms of the power
separation of power but you always ask
yourself who's watching those
individuals that run these branches of
power who is making sure that the
electeds are there to serve the people
are there to respond to those that
elected them you know it's hard in this
society today most of us today that work
8 to 5 some of us 8 to 8 have family
it's hard for us to take them off and
really be involved so we really have to
turn to those individuals to sound the
alert
that keep us updated that makes sure
that they keep the the electeds honest
you know Steve Greenhut is one of those
individuals as an elected I've got to be
honest with you
this gentleman and I've had many
conversations many times we've agreed
and many times we've agreed to disagree
but that's what democracy is about being
an elected government is supposed to be
responsive it's supposed to be
transparent and that's why one of the
ways Steve and I actually became better
friends west of the city of Garden Grove
in that situation it happened I still to
this day cannot believe that a municipal
government its electeds had a secret
plan
forget about eminent domain they had a
secret plan to do away with a thousand
residents now I beyond even asking
myself is this good policy to have an
amusement park the fact that government
had a secret plan to do away with it the
homes the castles with a thousand
residents
that's unbelievable comes to mind that's
saying that any government that's big
enough to give you everything is also
big enough to take everything away from
you and on behalf of my constituents I'd
like to thank Steve for everything he's
done for my constituents in Central
Orange County thank you very much Steve
you know one point I found that this is
a bipartisan issue
I mean Democrats and Republicans should
be able to agree on on this specific
issue that we can we shouldn't be taking
property and giving it to big retailers
so so there's a lot of room I've noticed
that folks have agreed with me they come
from all over the political map and it's
an important point that this is
something people should be united in
being able to fight now I want to
introduce Sean O'Connor who represented
Cottonwood Christian Center who the city
of Cypress was trying to take their
property to give it to a Costco I
suppose I'm one of those costly
attorneys that Steve referred to a bit
ago I am an eminent domain attorney and
I had the honor and the privilege of
representing Cottonwood Christian Center
in its battle against the city of
Cypress and Steve asked me to spend just
a couple of minutes talking about that
case cottonwood was a rapidly growing
Christian Church and was looking to find
a new location it had worked hard and
spent a lot of money in assembling
several different pieces of property and
eventually came up with an 18 acre piece
of property that it thought was ideal
for its church needs the problem was the
city of Cypress also found that property
be yet to be ideal but for a Costco we
ran into some problems in the
entitlement process we didn't get the
permits that we wanted and we learned
that the city of Cypress in fact had
other plans for our property and plan to
take it from us through the power of
eminent domain and sell it to Costco we
didn't think that was a very nice thing
for them to do so we filed a lawsuit in
federal district court in Orange County
thankfully we were successful in in
stopping a clear abuse of the power of
eminent domain and the judges Steve
alluded to granted our preliminary
injunction which effectively stopped the
city from taking any further steps in
acquiring on our property through the
power of eminent domain I think there
are a number of reasons why we
ultimately succeeded in that case we had
a courageous client that was willing to
reach
and spend the money in advance some
relatively novel legal theories but
certainly one of the main reasons we
were successful is because of courageous
journalists like Steve and I think Steve
was at the very forefront of bringing
this issue to public awareness and just
by way of example at the City Council
meeting where the city of Cyprus
ultimately voted to take our property to
the power of eminent domain after
numerous articles by Steve there were a
thousand people literally a thousand
people in attendance at City Hall
protesting ultimately it didn't stop the
city from going forward but I think it
did get the court's attention and we
heard after the fact that the clerk's
and the judge were well aware of this
lawsuit through the good work of Steve
and other journalists and they were
waiting for us to file our papers and
ultimately ruled in our favor so I'm
hopeful that with the success we had in
our case and with the public awareness
that is now out there due to the things
of people like Steve we're going to
begin to see an end of the abuse of
eminent domain thank you introduce Larry
Gilbert is an activist in Mission Viejo
and Larry's one of the first people who
introduced me to the whole issue of
eminent domain and redevelopment abuse
and Larry have if you can't get any kind
of sense with the people you're dealing
with on a city or the county level
picketing is a great solution as well as
trying to find people that are
candidates for a city council because
the generally have a new City Council
half and half every two years but I want
to stop and thank Steve and the Orange
County Register for the amount of ink
and paper that you have used to get this
message out because it's a complex
subject it allowed me to get a couple
stories out on the Garden Grove issue
but as I see verlan amber here and this
is the picket sign she gave me when I
sat next to Steve with between 800 and a
thousand people fighting for their
property rights I'd like to talk about
homeland security homeland security is
not an issue that came as a result of
9/11 we lost Homeland Security
Behrman versus parker as Steve alluded
to earlier and I'm just gonna repeat one
sentence that Steve quoted if Congress
decides that the nation's capital shall
be beautiful as well as sanitary there
was nothing in the fifth amendment that
stands in the way close quote I want to
read you our Constitution We the People
last part of the fifth amendment nor
shall private property be taken for
public use without just compensation
we're not talking about public use here
we're talking about private use there's
nothing in the Constitution that allows
the government to take your property and
give it to a Costco or Walmart or anyone
else and we're stuck with that court
decision I testified in Sacramento for
Tom McClintock and during one of the
hearings that I attended I met a young
man named Ron Zell Cato fifth-generation
African American first one to ever be
able to afford to own a piece of America
he owned a home up in Fresno I want to
read you the response after he testified
by Alan Roodhouse senior vice president
fair lawn development services and this
is his testimony quote if you get over
three or four properties that you have
to assemble the mechanics of it are such
that you're almost guaranteed at lost at
least one and maybe more parties who
simply won't deal with you they don't
want to sell and under our laws and our
property ownership rights they don't
have to close quote he went on to say
that implicit in the redevelopment law
is the notion that there are
circumstances where the public good
justifies violating that rule
close quote I have the tape from
Sacramento with me it said when here's a
man who had his home at the time land
was selling for ten to twenty dollars a
square foot but once they declared it
blighted an eminent domain they offered
him a dollar ten a square foot that's
the price you pay when Big Brother comes
rolling in and right now roxtor Foods is
they're eating very well with a turkey
processing plant what used to be his
home there's another story that Steve
and I cover together that's in this
fantastic book and by the way I bought
the book I paid full price and I've read
it cover to cover and it's must reading
and it's not just for you there could be
a family member back East somewhere it's
not just your home it's your business
in the lake elsinore case the argument
they were using is that the homeless a
lot of my double-wide Mobile's had
asbestos and lead based paint now if
that Steve the way we're gonna analyze
it how many millions of mobile homes
around the country would fall into that
same category
they should be grandfathered protected
and left alone but the argument that was
raised while standard and well
maintained these parcels are
substantially surrounded by otherwise
blighted parcels leaving such parcels
out of the sub area would create a Swiss
cheese effect with many holes in which
the agency cannot be active in other
words they wanted to wipe out hundreds
of home for redevelopment even though
some of these homes were perfectly
maintained and again that's a great
story that Steve covered and I thank you
for being here today see I'd like to
take some questions I want to introduce
ver Allah and Leo Lambert who they were
two of the Garden Grove folks who who
fought you know they fought their their
battles yeah have something you want to
say or they were the ones who were going
to be driven off for theme park
development I just want to say that we
wouldn't have been able to fight this
project without the health of the other
residents and people like Steve and
Larry and the media and we also Lew was
there to guide us and also jodan we had
lots of help and I do think that his
Steve's book is very good and like he
said it helps you everywhere because
this is everywhere it does spread and so
just read his book and be aware and
fortunately we were excuse me we're
taken out of the project so we didn't
have the great fight that the Costco
folks or the Cottonwood church had with
Costco's
but so we was out early thank you
thanks for coming okay - do we have any
questions
oh yeah if you could come up to the
oh okay just on my coverage at the
Orange County Register we've I saw lots
of lots of issues where people were
losing their property and I wrote a lot
about it became one of my big issues and
property rights as a huge concern so it
seemed like a a natural thing and happy
it's done
yes ma'am
yeah it I think on a lot there are there
are various ways that eminent domain
could be used on genuinely public
projects it doesn't need to be in a
redevelopment area but when it and also
I mentioned folks with questions I'll
use the mic and we can hear it better
but the main thing with redevelopment
agencies is they create an area where
you say okay this this area is we want
to improve this areas so we go through a
process of making it a redevelopment
area and what happens though once you're
in that area your property rights are
suspended to a certain degree because
that's what what the folks in Garden
Grove found we can't we can't sell our
home and we because who's going to buy
it knowing that it could be taken any
time so that's one of the tools that's
what city officials cool it call it a
tool is REIT is eminent domain and it
goes hand-in-hand with redevelopment
it's possible to create redevelopment
areas as some cities have and leave out
the eminent domain tool and a lot of
times cities will do that just to
capture property taxes and that's where
it gets kind of complex and our eyes all
glaze over when we start talking about
tax increment financing so I'll spare
that discussion but as it's a tax
capture mechanisms essentially cities
will steal property taxes from counties
and we'll do that without including
eminent domain but in the case in Garden
Grove
even though city officials lied about it
it was clear that they had in mind
driving the people off so that they can
have use eminent domain or a lot of
times the threat of eminent domain
attorney Chris Sutton I want one of the
folks who was a been a long source for
me he talks about how cities will brag
that well we never really use I'm going
to Maine or we've only used to two or
three times but it's like the mugger you
put a gun to people's head and most
people just hand over their wallets they
don't need to actually be shot and
that's the the threat of eminent domain
is enough to change the whole dynamic of
imagine negotiating for a house or a car
if you knew that if the person didn't
like the price they could just take it
from you so obviously that changes the
whole negotiating dynamic yes yes ma'am
and yeah I've come up to the mic and
they retired to a home but they plan to
live in for several years and the state
of North Carolina wants to build a
Greenbelt going from smoking Smoky
Mountains all the way out to the ocean
and the state wants to come in and take
part of their backyard to build a
Greenbelt and they're worried that the
value of their home is going to go down
significantly because of this what
advice would you have for them and
trying to fight this
my advice is always the same get a good
lawyer and and one of the things even
people who can't afford don't feel as if
they can afford legal help to fight you
need the legal help to know what to do
to fight so certain attorneys I know
will suggest hiring an attorney early on
- at least there are very specific
deadlines and requirements for for
registering objections to redevelopment
plants and you need to know when those
are and people who who don't get
competent legal advice aren't able to
fight effectively usually though well
many times it's it's not the legal fight
that'll stop it it's the political fight
but but it's always helpful to have a
lawyer's advice to tell you and sir.you
that a question from what you've been
saying there's a lot of misconduct by
public officials lawyers appraisers
developers have you discovered any
instances where these people have been
punished penalized for their misconduct
as a disincentive for others or do they
just always get away with it I've never
I've never seen it I think that
misconduct has to get to the level of
theft before anyone's punished but in
terms of lying to people about what's
going on and not giving proper notice
and
abusing the Constitution things that
strike me as abusive I've never seen
punishment you know or any any kind of
recourse that I could I could think of I
wanted to know if you've discovered any
laws that are being proposed or enacted
and there's three different areas I want
to ask you so I'll ask you one at a time
so I don't confuse you one is do you
know of any laws that are being proposed
to give penalties for misconduct I've
never heard of any proposal of that kind
that would change the way eminent domain
proceedings operate such as a federal
law stating at no state or local
official can take property unless they
can prove to a competent judge that the
use is truly for the public good yeah
there are different proposals and
because this is ultimately a local and
state government problem there are
different there are different proposals
some to deal with public use making it
more specific with public uses and
they're there smattering of laws there
aren't that many that have been proposed
I discussed six or seven of them and in
the book but there hasn't been I'm not
aware of any major federal legislation I
know senator chuck pachoo Gihon
Republican from Fresno had proposed I
forget the specifics of it but it was an
excellent law that would have reigned in
eminent domain abuse at the in
Sacramento at the California level and
it went absolutely nowhere just after
years of battle the New York State
Legislature passed and the governor
Pataki finally signed a law that does
get this requires that condemning
agencies have to notify the property
owner so I mean just to get that was a
huge deal just to get a law passed to
require proper notification of people
before before they passed the law and
the Institute for justice did an
excellent job on this on it's a
washington-based interest group that
that fights for for property owners and
they they helped propose that law but
before that the state didn't have to
notify they would just notify a general
neighborhood they didn't have to
provide individual notices so even
getting what strikes me as should be the
bare minimum you should have a have a
personal notice before you're being
driven off your property but even
getting that advancement is a tough road
so I know there's in Colorado there's
there's a some kind of law that's been
proposed that would deals with the whole
public use issue and but there isn't
nearly as much as there should be but
not entirely was do you know of any laws
requiring notice to landowners at the
design stage when they public officials
are first talking about it not after
things have already progressed so one of
the problems is when they're just
talking about it there's nothing no harm
has been committed yet so and a lot of
times cities will try to keep it keep
this quiet you know so that's I know
I've not not seen anything like that and
I'm not sure how how wouldn't would do
that but thanks very much sir
yes sir and this December it by
extortion didn't it said we will use
them a domain if you don't sell gobbled
up over 14,000 private acres for private
use it in in the light of that I
understand that there is a case pending
before the US Supreme Court where
Connecticut is threatening to do another
poll town do you have any any comment on
that case yeah I'm not that familiar
with the case I know in Connecticut
there are a couple Connecticut cases
that I wrote about one there often
similar there was one dealing with some
property owners and who lived along a
riverfront area but I can't really speak
to speak to the case on yeah thanks oh
yes sir
I live in Yorba Linda and which where we
are right now city of your Belinda over
five miles that way is what's called
downtown your Belinda and in that in
that area there were there was some
small
retail or there's a automotive sections
and a you know little hollow that was
like Lake Wobegon but just towns about
100 years old and it was deemed blight
and the city took it over they have they
have delusions of creating a marvelous
town center there that'll be the mecca
of Orange County and part of that the
number of my question is eminent domain
versus blight involving blight and also
social engineering and racism - down in
the downtown area there - were two large
apartment complexes facing each other on
Plum Ossa street and they were inhabited
by low-income people one was went the
eminent domain way and it was gentrified
you can't even get in there because it's
such such demand for this place it's
lovely it's it has some kind of rent
subsidy system set in there across the
street are hundreds and hundreds of
other apartments that were built 40 50
years ago that they also the city also
wanted to acquire so that's the last
real low-income area in the city wants
the wants to tear it down and put in a
eminent a city can't the real estate
have a developer come in and create
low-cost housing which to replace the
low cost housing that is already there
on the free enterprise market that
people in Yorba Linda the people it's
it's it's this town has a median income
on 85 thousand I believe but down there
you see people walking to McDonald's
from these places and they're working in
fast food restaurants and they are
really the laboring people of your
Belinda the Phillies fill these jobs so
if they shut down that area
to let in gentrified low-cost housing
renters it seems to be it seems to be
sort of a unique phenomenon as opposed
to let's say the blatant thing that
Robert Moses did in New York let's say
where the World Trade Center was taking
hundreds of acres driving hundreds of
thousands of people and small businesses
out to create a vast empty lot so long
could put up two big towers and or to
relocate certain ethnic areas from from
the city to god-knows-where to suburbia
and so there's there's things I think
playing in the East and West Coast that
a little different you know big town
versus little but I I have a feeling
you're going to be writing more on this
and it's it is happening everywhere and
a lot of a lot of things back east or
similar to how it's being done here the
laws differ in every state but it's true
that whenever there's a lower income
area city officials will often think
that's blighted and a lot of times small
small locally owned businesses are
viewed as blighted because there's a
preference for big national chain stores
and what happens is a lot of these first
rung on the economic ladder places get
get obliterated and then where you're
supposed to go and start a small
business I know business owners who've
had two or three or four times have been
victims of eminent domain for the
obvious reason that maybe they're a
small restaurateur and often it'll be an
immigrant restaurant tour in places like
Garden Grove older areas and and they go
into it's a lower-cost area and then
they get driven out so that we can build
a chain store and then they go to
another lower-cost area that's
affordable and they get driven out again
so that's why we I'm always advocating
for the free market and I think what
Anaheim is doing is a better better
approach where where you loosen up
zoning give people an opportunity to to
redevelop on their own but the market in
my view is always preferable to central
plan I thank you for writing the book I
mean it's marvelous I bought two of them
gave one away so just everyone else do
the same song Thanks
this is uh
mayor Bob Huff of my home city of
Diamond Bar good to see you here
addressing this issue we're looking at
the what here but my question is why
don't we look at the why because if
you're going to address it you need to
look at why are cities and counties
doing this I believe it has to do with
them changing redevelopment agencies and
economic development agencies mostly
because of prop 13 ab8 changed the way
that local governments are financed so
they look for a way an existing tool
that they could modify for their own
uses I think that's what's seen
widespread abuse for it so I'm wondering
if you have given consideration to and
what your thoughts are of taking away
the property tax incentive or excuse me
the sales tax incentive because that's
why they want to go after big boxes the
sales tax generate revenues if that
doesn't go to local government that
should be less reason why they would
want to encourage that as opposed to
other things that increase property
increment houses do that it's just that
they don't know it's such a dramatic way
where they can also get sales tax
revenue well that's a good point and
we're hoping when you win your assembly
race you'll do the proposed legislation
like that in Sacramento won't it one of
the things that needs to be done in
Sacramento is changing the property
taxes person because cities are in a jam
and there's no question about it they
have limited revenues even though a lot
of cities waste money incredibly but
that's a whole nother issue but but the
fact is they are very very limited the
state always takes their funds and and
what happens is they're incentivized or
not a word but you know they're given
great incentives to build as many
big-box stores as possible because they
get one cent on every sale taxable
dollar in in the city so what they want
to do is create more sales taxes so they
use eminent domain as a tool to create
as many big-box stores and Costco's as
they can because those stores will
create an enormous amount of revenue for
a city where housing which is in a still
in a shortage around here and in other
areas they don't they don't get any kind
of financial benefit so if there's
something done in in Sacramento and it
really is a state state problem and
there there is a fixed needs there were
some proposals going on last year and
they kind of died on the vine but we're
big advocates for that at the register
and unchanging that because a lot of
times
cities are pushed to do these kind of
things so yep thank you oh I'm sorry I
didn't I tuned from Yorba Linda I don't
I'm kind of jotted down I hope I make
myself clear and your Linda had a
lawsuit with the school district of to
the tune of two hundred and fifty
million dollars and they did over Linda
lost that lawsuit and but they had a
court order that they could do no more
bounding down in the in town center
until it was settled they lost the
lawsuit but but they appealed it because
when they appealed it there are ten
years of eminent domain ran out and they
but they had they had to renew that 10
another ten years because they were
short there are three hundred units of
affordable senior citizen units so they
did although they did have a referendum
tried to stop him from the renewal there
ten years and they love they just
couldn't get enough votes but my
question is is it one of the reports
said that Jo was ten years maximum
I'm going to domain and so they renewed
it ten years to keep them or how why is
it not that they can keep renewing
renewing every ten years ten years until
the end of eternity there's a maximum I
have it's often grandfather well it's
time there's a time limit often but it
can be added back in and cities you know
they like to they'd like to have it in
there I about what you bring up an
interesting point cities and school
districts will fight because and the
whole financing mechanism the
redevelopment agencies are supposed to
provide a certain amount of funding to
those schools because schools lose
funding through redevelopment agencies
but sometimes it leads to legal cases
like with in Yorba Linda and also in
Garden Grove the the city Redevelopment
Agency was trying to stiff the school
does
so it creates a whole interesting
process of governments fighting with
each other over you know tax revenues
and it's it's a troubled process well
anyone out yes ma'am hello I'm Robin
marcario I live in Garden Grove and I
like the fact that you've touched on the
notification process that if you lobby
your representatives your council
members you can extend that notification
process and the more that you are
notified you're notified about the
process to go to Planning Commission and
voice your concerns there which is an
advisory level and ultimately the
decision is made at the council level
and they're the representatives they're
the ones that you should be talking with
if you want greater notice if you want
from 500 to 800 or a thousand yards or
whatever it is but you speak with your
council members and you can have an
input that is where you can make the
input and the more you're notified and
books like this that you put together
your to be a committed mr. green a green
hood this is part of the educational
process how you can get involved local
you can have an impact on your City
Council provided you know some City
Council's are so devoted to this process
that they try to do whatever they can to
sneak it through and there you're not
gonna have a lot of impact but
redevelopment in California is a every
redevelopment agency even though they're
run by the cities there's state agencies
so there is need for statewide reform
and any way or any other questions or
well thank you oh yes sir
when it comes to the revenue now and new
housing and all these new hotels and all
this now let me give you an example what
happened in Garden Grove the city had
just passed an agreement with a builder
for 42 homes on Gilbert and Katella
now it wasn't financially feasible for
him to do this so the city gave eight
point seven five million for the
property selling it to developer first
point-five we lost two and a quarter
million bucks but it gets better they're
going to give them 80% of the new taxes
for 20 years the city gets 20% to pay
off the debt where's the revenue maybe
that's the City of Garden Grove calling
in a Leo well thank you all for coming
out I'll be signing books in right now
so thanks again for your comments
[Applause]
Tuesday the Supreme Court accepted an
appeal involving eminent domain abuse of
power is published by seven locks press
visit seven locks press